[Music]
thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Piers Morgan I'm censored tonight
the stunning arrogance the hypocrisy of
canceled culture there's public backlash
to a trans marathon runner and an attack
on The Late Barry Humphries so the woke
worm May finally be turning will debate
another presidential candidate is
uncensored Robert Kennedy Jr yes one of
the Kennedys known as the Black Sheep
act of America's most famous political
Dynasty but could he put a serious dent
in Biden's bid for re-election his poll
numbers are surging and he joins me live
and a final thought on a cultural icon
and a great friend of mine legendary
talk show host Jerry Springer who was on
America's Got Talent with me and Sharon
Osborne will be on the show tonight and
we're going to pay tribute to the late
great Jerry Springer
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening Rolanda welcome to Piers
Morgan on sense it's impossible to read
a newspaper turn on the TV or browse any
social media without running head first
into a wall of virtue signaling Babble
it's engineered to make you feel like a
terrible person at the hands of a
condescending mob policing their own
private rule book on integrity and
ethics and most of them are stinking
Hypocrites take a late great Barry
Humphries the Melbourne International
Comedy Festival and his native Australia
has announced it will arrange a fitting
tribute to a man they now call a comic
genius okay so far so good he was but
then you remember that a few years ago
the very same organization publicly
disowned him Barry Humphries it had the
temerity to say he was worried about the
way gender ideology was now being pushed
on young kids in schools so the
festival's director Susan provan who
this week hail Barry Humphries as an
incredible artist Led the original
charge against him
absolutely condemning his unhelpful
opinions after that he was of course
branded a fascist transphobe as anyone
that raises any questions about all this
is immediately branded and the festival
stripped his name from The Barry award
they quoted in his honor
they canceled it and that decision hurt
Barry Humphries personally as his
closest friends have attested how
couldn't it this was his world the
comedy world in his country
and they stripped it away from him
another very same people who did that to
Barry Humphries want us to forget they
ever did this forget that they chucked
him under the wheels of their Walt
morality bus to score a few cheap points
at their smug dinner parties and bags
and bags and validation on Twitter well
frankly they can shove it they can shove
their endorsement of Barry Humphries now
that he's dead
they never uncanceled him when he was
alive and they shouldn't be allowed to
do it now
and then we come to this
Clinique here not your first marathon I
believe no this will be 17 and I'm doing
the six Majors so I've just done Tokyo
and New York last year and then this
year Chicago Berlin
2024 will be the number six and then
that's a week before London so a weak
rest but trick girl power
yeah that's actually the first marathon
though that that particular guest on the
BBC had run as a woman
of the 40 000 athletes running the
London Marathon the BBC decided to
interview Glennie Frank
and apparently transgender woman who
unsurprisingly placed ahead of 14 000
biological females in the race because
Glenn eek ran the New York Marathon in
November last year as Glenn
a man
now all week we've been hected about why
this is Progressive and wonderful the
rest of us who question this are wicked
Biggers and transfers are suggesting
there might be a fairness issue here
with somebody who has run as a male
through to their 50s including only a
few weeks ago in New York and is now
identifying as female and demolishing a
lot of the feel
well now the runner in question has
apologized Clinique Glenn
has offered to hand back their medal and
said they will run in the mail category
in future as Glenn so no longer Clinic
and so the mob has of course dispersed
the facts don't fit their agenda anymore
and nothing better spells out doesn't it
the intransigence of this culture
then the transgender swim in America
Leah Thomas who far from being cowed by
the perfectly Justified criticism from
fair-minded people who think is just
plainly wrong that a six foot four inch
biological male who was unsuccessful
competing against men in swimming
competitions is now demolishing
biological females after identifying as
a woman well not only apparently are we
all wrong for questioning that says Leah
Thomas but we're also all of us male and
female bad feminists
you can't really have that that sort of
half support where you're like oh I
respect you as a woman here but not here
they're using the guys of feminism to
sort of push transphobic uh beliefs and
I think a lot of people in that camp
sort of carry an implicit bias against
trans people but don't one I guess fully
manifest or speak that out and so they
try to just play it off as the sort of
half support
hmm I wonder you could be thinking about
is sort of half in half out as my friend
Martina rattle over a Legendary
Legendary gay feminist sportswoman put
it stop explaining feminism to feminists
but of course Leah Thomas won't care
Leah Thomas's winning races that she
would not be winning if she was still
competing as a man making a ton of money
appearing on all the top media all the
magazine covers there's a lot of money
being made in this area right now and
they don't think they're right they know
they're right we're the ones that are
wrong and if we dare raise a scintilla
of an issue about any of this we are
transphobic we're the Bad Guys
and gals and they attack like a swarm of
locusts don't they on social media for a
fleeting moment of self-righteous thrill
because as they're so fond of telling us
they are on the right side of History
until it's with Barry Humphries it turns
out actually they're not
that actually they were on the wrong
side of history after all and they just
want us to pretend we never knew
well I'm joined now by the British
Olympic marathon runner Mara Yamauchi
and by rapper and pogasto Zoo big great
to see you here zubi who once took part
in a weightlifting competition four
years ago as a woman to kind of prove a
point and guess what
he won and by talk TV contributor Paula
Roan Adrian who will still be attempting
to defend the indefensible on this issue
well Clinique Frank uh just to be clear
or Glenn Frank whichever uh Glenn or
glenick is identifying as this week was
invited to appear but pulled out this
morning and like I say uh Glennie or
Glenn again we don't know because
Lenny's going back to being Glennon
future races and has always run as Glenn
before
um did did say it was wrong but you are
asked when you enter the London Marathon
which category do you want to run it
male or female
or non-binary
it's ridiculous the whole thing is
ridiculous as I keep saying but there
are still people who think this is
perfectly fair and equal and we should
all just stop making such a fuss about
it so let's have a little chat about
this uh we'll see let me start with you
because you come all the way in here
great to see you in London I love the
fact that you tested almost four years
ago and you did it to raise the problem
as an issue and of course you demolished
all the females that you're up against
because physically as a biological male
You're simply more powerful but you
expose the futility if you like and I'm
fairness and inequality of self-identity
if it becomes Limitless like this yeah
absolutely
um I've been talking for more than five
years at this point but especially the
past four publicly about the absurdity
of the issue and that's why back in
February 2019 I had that tweet I put out
there with a video of me breaking the
British women's deadlift record while
claiming I identified as you literally
broke the women's record yeah so to be
clear it wasn't in a sanctioned
competition but it was from one of my
training sessions just showing how
easily I could lift a weight that's well
we're looking at it this is you as a
woman yeah it wasn't exactly Difficult
about 17 Paula Ron Adrians and I know
you're like a bit of weightlifting Paul
I said why don't you try and lift a bit
of that later in your gym we'll see how
you get on there's a spoiler alert you
won't be able to
um not because you're not a very strong
lady and not because you're not a very
committed athlete in your own right
because if the biological differences no
do you get it myself it's the penny
dropping so I get it but what I wonder
is whether you get it peers what am I
missing what I wonder is why it is
you're struggling with the fact that
some people are different I don't and
and the people who have decided that
they are different and who want to live
a different life some of them have the
capacity to do that medically and
legally and they should be permitted
always have done always supported trans
people's rights to fairness inequality
okay so right right to the point it
clearly erodes women's rights that's my
only concern about it so where the
absurdity comes I worry is where we've
got this example of the marathon runner
and this was a fun run it's the marathon
it's not a fun run right it's awesome
it's a great no no tens of thousands of
people raise a ton of money and it's a
serious competitive rate it's a great
example of people getting the
opportunity to push themselves not only
personally but also in terms of their
charitable Charities and this is a
person who did that and they are nice
and so fearful they've had to apologize
they've had to offer to hand back their
medal well they want their fearful
because because Glenn entered as Glenn
eek and Glennie finished a lot further
in the race in the women's field than
Glenn would have done in the men's field
and how relevant is that to you peers
actually to everyone I know to everybody
I know that racism a London marathon
every position counts they all want to
improve their time it wasn't a gold
medal actually the ones this was the
Front Runners in the London it was about
taking part do you think it's
meaningless London Marathon no
absolutely it's actually taken I've I've
it's actually one of them and I see and
people running past me I see people
running past me of all different sizes
shapes uh running for all different
types of causes and that's what it's all
about it's inclusivity but let me bring
in an actual Olympians rather than
somebody who sounds like she thinks
you're to be one uh Mara you've been
listening very patiently uh to all this
you've been a proper athlete here just
try and explain to me or to Paula really
why this is so unfair
foreign
so males and females have there's a
massive difference in our physical
abilities in upper body strength like in
zooby's uh bench press and deadlift uh
Women's World Records you know there's a
massive massive difference in running
it's about 10 therefore we must have
sex-based categories male and female
otherwise females would be entirely
absent from Sport and to answer Paula's
point about it being a fun run yes a lot
of people in enjoy it and do great
things like raising money but Glenn
could have done that in the men's
category and not caused unfairness for
the 20 000 odd females who ran in the in
the mass race I have to also clarify
that Glenn ran as Glenn in the Tokyo
Marathon last month but also in the
women's category as he did in London and
you know you can say well the mass race
is just a bit of fun the mass race at
the London Marathon but an event like
that is either a sports competition or
it isn't if you're going to say it's
just a fun run then why do they have a
measured course why do they have timing
equipment and a referee to enforce the
rules you know even if people enjoy
themselves and and earn and raise money
for charity it still is a comp a
competition rules matter and people have
to respect the rules and Glenn on on GB
news gave an interview last night it was
clear he had no idea what the rules are
he was talking about uh surgery and
passports but the rules British
Athletics rules which apply to the
London Marathon required testosterone
suppression to under five nanomoles for
12 months to become eligible and then
continue suppression to remain eligible
he was talking about hormone therapy in
the future tense so it's clear he's done
no testosterone suppression at all he
wasn't eligible for the female category
and therefore my view is he should be
disqualified because he he hasn't he's
just not he's not eligible well no
question there's no question of that I
mean what's interesting to me two things
about about you in particular one your
courage in speaking out about this
because you were of course immediately
bombarded with insults and abuse and
threats called a transphobe a Turf their
favorite phrase for stating what a
simple biological facts but also you are
but you're in a mission you're slightly
left leaning you're not on the right
you're not trying to score some
political Point against the left and
like a lot of people I mean I you know
I've always probably politically been
slightly left to Center maybe Center I'm
really a journalist I don't really care
about an ideology either way to be
honest with you but
um I'm certainly not on the right but
like a lot of people like you like me
like Bill Maher interviewed last week in
America we find ourselves completely
bemused that people so-called liberals
on this Ultra woke side now the of the
spectrum I've lost their minds
yeah I mean I've been a center-left
voter all my life but for me this isn't
about left or right for me this is about
the rights to safety dignity privacy and
in sport Fair competition and safety for
51 of the population and people say oh
Clinique only finished 6100 and
something you know get a life but nearly
000 women suffered a worse finished
position what I would say to people who
say that is okay how many women do you
think it's okay to suffer to indulge the
feelings of one male competing in the
female give us a number yeah I totally
agree and what about I mean I said Paula
what about Laurel Hubbard the New
Zealand weightlifter who qualified uh
for the first Olympics a couple of years
ago having said
records in the women's field but she
took the place of a woman weightlifter
the average age for the weightlifters in
that competition was about half Laurel
Harbor's age she'd been very
unsuccessful as a male weightlifted by
comparison but she deprived a biological
female of an Olympic place in that team
that to me is completely wrong now
someone said to be on TV in America last
week a female congresswoman well what
would you do about it then I went well
fine I want trans athletes to compete
fairly and to be able to compete so they
either compete against their biological
sex which seems to me physically fair or
they have a completely new category of
transport why not so there's there's two
things here just getting back to the
marathon if if Clinique wasn't eligible
then there's no discussion here because
absolutely if if she wasn't eligible
then she wasn't eligible
what I'm talking about in terms of the
marathon is when I ran the marathon I
was running with men and women uh young
people older people all running together
and what I'm saying is is this fear that
the headlines around this is bringing up
it's bringing up a fear it's making very
vulnerable people and we know that
they're very vulnerable because we're
told by the stats that they are the most
likely group of people to commit suicide
so this is not just about a fun run this
is not just about women who require
vulnerable spaces this is not what we're
talking okay I would say to that the the
of course I'm very aware of the issues
that trans people have had and continue
to have but I think people like Leah
Thomas people like glenick here they
cause massive bigger problems for the
trans Community they make the whole
thing look like a mockery yeah they make
a mockery of being trans yeah and when
you put your hand up as a six foot four
inch biological manner say I am now
competing against women in swimming pool
no trans person who doesn't want that
attention is doing anything other than
saying this is making my life hell why
are you doing this yeah you're
absolutely right in that the so-called
activists are harming the group that
they're claiming to advocate for as well
as harming 51 of the of the whole human
population because let's be real all of
this stuff all the negative Downstream
impacts are on girls on women they are
not on boys and men at all I'd say this
whole thing is incredibly misogynistic
and I don't like to throw that word
around too much today conversation up a
level as well I have a question and the
whole thing is why are we trying to
force people and why are so many people
entertaining the denial of reality
itself yeah women's rights are
incredibly important fairness in sports
is important safety and security and
privacy all of these things are very
important the fundamental problem at the
root of this is everyone dancing around
pretending that a man can truly be a
woman and a woman can truly be a man
this is not me being transphobic or
hateful or being a bigot anything like
that it's simply that reality exists
biology is real and is that reality
legal one because
reality zubi that you can change your
gender you cannot change your biological
sex it's physically impossible I'm I'm
saying to you it is impossible
can you change your biology we can talk
about biology and we can talk about the
legality we're talking about biology
though we're talking this thing is about
sport this is about males and females
well the problem when we talk about
biology is either us a scientists
you and I both know that it's a lot more
complicated it's not as simple as for me
it's very interesting you it may be very
simple but we are I think we're being
we're indulging and ignorant suggest can
you become can you become can you become
male I don't want to be you can is there
anything that could be done that could
turn you into a male in the way that I'm
a male empiricism is that is that
possible now do you see how you've
qualified your question so you first ask
me can you can you can I be can I become
in the mail and I would suggest probably
yes in terms of medically but
[Music]
legally become a male we've got to leave
it there but you can't actually become a
biological male
female because I'm quite tempted right
now to start entering the cricket
competition right and smashing female
biological Bowlers all over the place of
feeling good about myself only I
wouldn't I'd feel ashamed I think I
think it's embarrassing your uh pumping
above your weight there
it is female cricketers as I say wait
till Usain Bolt goes I'm identifying as
a woman it runs an 100 meter final at
the Olympics and you'll all go well done
well done you see me hold on you see me
it's a joke uh anyway Paula lovely to
see you tomorrow thank you very much for
joining us it's gonna be great to have
you here in London really appreciate you
coming into uh and go follow this guy on
Twitter who just passed a million
followers on Twitter so only seven and a
half million to catch me
uh which I know he's Keen to do on sense
of next tributes to a true legend the
original King of talk television a great
guy a great friend of mine Jerry
Springer who sadly died today at age 79
what a life and what a guy we'll talk
live to Sharon Osborne who work with me
and Jerry on America's Got Talent and to
still Steve Wilkos of course his great
colleague from his show which became the
Springer Show one of the biggest shows
on the entire planet that's after the
break
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
you're thinking it we're talking about
it
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
well welcome back Jerry Springer was the
in Undisputed King of the talk show
smart intelligent TV icon it was also a
politician a lawyer an actor he could do
it all I spent nearly every day for two
years with him on the set of America's
Got Talent we stayed in the same Hotel
the Beverly Wilshire in Los Angeles we
used to sit by the pool talking about
politics we'd have dinner talking about
politics he loved arguing about politics
you've been a mayor before he ever
became a TV star and he was most
definitely uncensored
[Applause]
good evening good evening good evening
good evening very much welcome to the
show thank you and welcome to America's
Got Talent
daddy issues I would like to get our
Dairy views
I care about people I care about people
who watch television and on that note
take care of yourself
well today Jerry's family said Jerry's
ability to connect with people was at
the heart of his success and everything
he tried whether that was politics
broadcasting or just joking with people
on the street who wanted a photo or a
word he's Irreplaceable and his loss
hurts immensely the memories of his
intellect his heart and his humor will
live on and he bought his usual warmth
and energy as a regular guests on all my
shows that I did ever since we did that
talent show together
do you think Matthew McConaughey and
this extraordinary speech could actually
affect change certainly it'll have some
impact but the fact is the American
people are virtually all or pretty close
to all in agreement on the major idea of
some kind of gun control what can Trump
do to try and persuade you now that he's
a unifier and not a destroyer well just
personally I I would I will do
everything I can to see that he becomes
a successful president I think I may
stop because there are the things I want
to do I want to spend more time with
Richard my grandson and follow him in
baseball and basketball and do things
like that so it's more that decision
more than a medical decision
Jerry could talk about anything and he
could talk about it for hours and he was
always entertaining always funny and
always Razor Smart always knew exactly
what was going on he was also a great
friend and I'll give you just two little
examples of that one uh he was doing I
think it was Richard and Judy a few
years ago with Amanda Holden he was
doing Britain's Got Talent with me and
Amanda put me on the phone too and I
said Jerry what are you doing tonight he
said nothing I said do you want to come
to my middle son's school they're doing
sounded music and Amanda's host and me
and Michael grade is a big media Mogul
in Britain we're dressing up as nuns and
we need a Catholic priest to dress up as
a Catholic priest he went I'm Jewish I
went I know you are he said my Rabbi
would be fine with it and he came down
and he went on stage as a Catholic
priest with me as a nun and we sang
Sound of Music songs and then a little
later after that I have an annual
cricket match against my little village
down in East Sussex and I said Jerry
what are you doing on Sunday he went
nothing I went fancy game of cricket you
went I'd love one and he came all way
down to the south coast of England and
we play cricket and the villagers
absolutely loved him and in fact on our
village WhatsApp chat today a lot of
sadness because they all remembered how
down to earth this TV Legend was
everyone knew Jerry Springer so that was
the real guy away from TV there were no
flies on Jerry eat what you saw was what
you got and he was one of the great guys
well join me on the phone now
is my fellow talk TV presenter and my
fellow former America's Got Talent judge
Sharon Osborne and the former director
of security of course on the Jerry
Springer Show turned talk show host
himself now Steve Wilkos uh well Sharon
let me start with you
um you know Jerry we worked with him
didn't we handy glovery for two years
it's very intense on most shows you get
to know each other really really well I
remember and I'm sure you too the time
we all first met each other was a dinner
thrown by NBC where you lost your rank
let's start with we mean to go on
because it was so fitting because we'd
all had this quiet dinner then you lost
your rag with me and began to actually
physically throttle me and at that point
Jerry got up and said this reminds me of
one of my shows and led you away
he did he took me outside and he said
take some rest now I want you to go home
and think about this and I said yes
Jerry and um he was just amazing with me
he I mean listen in our religion we call
him moment and that's what he is I mean
just a fantastic human being he I loved
the way he always ended his show on a on
a great speech you know morally it was
always a takeaway from his show so it
wasn't just you know people going crazy
at each other throwing things and
whatever there was always a good moral
at the end of his show and you know what
I guess sorry Shane go on so now I'm
just saying that he will be missed he
was a Pioneer on daytime TV yeah
yeah and he used to say he's a joke it's
the worst show in the world but it was
also one of the most popular and one of
the most lucrative made him extremely
rich but he always had a great warmth
and was very protective towards all the
people that came on let me go to just
let me go to Steve now
um Steve I'm so sorry for your loss
because he was so closely aligned with
Jerry for so long and you made a very
moving statement today how are you doing
today since you heard the news
good stuff
um
I love Jerry and uh
one of my closest friends and you know
I'd still uh can't believe that I'm
never gonna talk with him again
you know he used to talk jokely about
the show but obviously it became this
complete phenomenon
um what did you make of the of why it
was so popular how much of that was the
guess how much of that was Jerry was it
just the the combination really yeah
yeah I think it was just a crazy point
of time and you know when I watched the
opening your show today and you were
talking about cancer culture I wonder
how far we would have got today yeah in
the landscape of today with that show
um listen you know I think Jerry was
just a natural draw people draw Tony is
very kind uh people love Jerry I mean
loved him and uh you know the craziness
on the show we were we were doing
stories and and things that you know you
couldn't see anywhere else on TV at the
time uh so I think it was uh Confluence
of things and the show just took off
like a rocket and I I've been saying
you're probably never going to see
anything like that again because you
know when we this show was so popular it
wasn't internet there wasn't streaming
you know nowadays if something's big and
huge it's big and huge for five minutes
right and then there's something else
where back then you know he was the
Zenith for two years we're beating Oprah
and everything else
um so to be around him I I felt like it
must have been like hanging around Elvis
Presley but what about this Steve what
about this uh Annie I'll tell you which
was I had dinner with with Jerry in La
soon after we began working together and
he told me story that Muhammad Ali was
an avid fan of the show and I gotta be
honest I didn't know Jerry that well I
just didn't believe him I thought it was
Hollywood bullcrat to be honest and we
walked back from Mr Charles in Beverly
Hills to the Beverly Wilshire Hotel
about a five ten minute walk and we get
to the valet parking area to go to the
back Wing where we both had rooms and a
limousine pulls up I swear this is true
I wrote about it in my diary at the time
a limousine pulls up and out gets
Muhammad Ali and his wife I've never met
muhammadu Ali in my life and as they get
out of the door she sees Jerry uh
Muhammad's wife and she just shouted oh
my God Jerry Springer pause he's still
watching the show and Muhammad Ali came
over Jerry introduced me to the greatest
and I said I hear you love the Springer
Show he went I I love it I love all the
fighting and then we all laughed and I
said please tell me you love America's
Got Talent too it's kind of a little bit
less committal on that but it just
showed me hey I could always trust Jerry
Springer after that uh but B that
everyone and anyone used to watch the
Springer Show
yeah not a lot of people admitted it but
uh everybody did watch it and uh you
know I met Muhammad too and you know
Muhammad told me he was a big fan so I
know that for a fact but uh you know
you're just they have a show that
Pete's so so highly worked everybody
talked about you know we most young
people won't understand what we say
about water cooler show everybody talked
about that show and uh I I feel very
fortunate to be around Jerry and got to
share that incredible ride with them uh
just you know we were we were doing
movies and you know Leto and Letterman
and everything else just traveling all
over the world with him and uh you know
to get the experience that with them and
you couldn't do it with a nicer guy
yeah I was about to bring Sharon back
for that Steve um I want to start a
little clip from America's Got Talent
because we had such a laugh on that show
together this is back in like 2007
aita thing but let's take a look at this
well pierce the exercise here but please
tell me we're not going to be hearing
those buzzers tonight it's my point
having them is there Jerry if you can't
have the fun of actually pressing them
we've all got itchy fingers tonight
let's see all right but you'll be nice I
will try and be nice Sharon what do
tonight's act have to do in order to
kind of impress you impress America
oh my goodness Where Do We Begin Jerry
they were great day Sharon and the thing
about Jerry Springer one he was one of
the nicest people I've ever worked with
no question and secondly just the most
professional he never turned up a minute
late he was always did his job whatever
the hours he's just a great guy do you
remember he is when he fell off the
stage and he would hurt himself
and on I mean he just carried on never
missed a beat and you know his show was
like a guilty pleasure
you know what people there aren't many
people left in the industry like Jerry
who was all heart real people person
yeah and what people don't know about
Jerry probably and they'll find out when
they read the obituaries it's the very
life he led before he did the Springer
Show he was a news anchor uh of a big TV
news show for 10 years he was the mayor
of Cincinnati for a year yeah um that
ended in a bit of a scandal which we
won't go into but he he he had this
extraordinary life and even at the end
nearly 80 there he was still doing loads
of stuff and doing podcasts doing
interviews and shots on but but he did
say in the final interview that we did
with him only last month that he was
looking forward as he reached 80 to
spend more time with his family which
was something he was very pleased
he was always doing charity events too I
mean he had such a big heart yeah well
it's a massive loss he's Irreplaceable
yeah he really is he was a total one-off
and we loved him didn't we Sharon thank
you so much for joining me from LA and
Steve thank you my deepest my deepest
condolences to you Steve because you and
he were intertwined for so long and I
can only imagine how you're feeling
today so I'm so glad to have you on the
show it's an honored to have you and it
was an honor for all of us to work with
Jerry
thanks thanks a lot I appreciate it
thanks Steve
the great Jerry Springer who died today
aged 79 but uncensored next tonight a
conspiracy theorist a Kennedy and a
presidential Contender Robert F Kennedy
Jr joins me live as he's surging in the
polls
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
welcome back to physical
Kennedy's on American political dynasty
of course so my next guest is will be
the fourth candidate to run for the U.S
presidency both his father attender
Robert F Kennedy and his uncle President
John F Kennedy were tragically
assassinated with Robert Kennedy Jr has
been described as the black sheep of
this formidable family including by some
of his own family was in send reviews on
vaccines and a popular slant on economic
policy but he could become a genuine
headache for President Biden he surged
at 19 in a new Fox News poll of
democratic candidates for nominee to be
president and 21 in a new Emerson poll
published today Robert F Kennedy Jr
joins me now well thank you very much
indeed for joining me uh I guess my
first question uh Robert is this these
polls they're pretty striking to
everybody else are you surprised about
how well you're doing
um I am I surprised I you know we've
been looking at the polls for
about a year and they're you know it's
pretty consistent so I'm not that
surprised I'm happy
you obviously come
um from the most famous political family
arguably in the world
and I want to take you back because I
think for a wider Global audience it's
just an extraordinary part of your story
obviously that you were just nine years
old when your uncle John F Kennedy was
president was assassinated you were 14
when your father who was tipped to be
and I'm sure he would have been one of
the great presidents if he'd lived uh
you were 14 when your father died you
had to be one of the pool bearers there
these are huge things to happen to any
child of that age but to do it when both
your uncle and your father were so
globally famous and to have their death
so widely reported what impact do you
think that had on you and what impact
has it had on you now as a politician
now running for president
well I think it had an impact on the
world I think my father and Uncle were
fighting against this emergence of the
military-industrial complex and their
deaths really marked a fork in a road
for our country and for the rest of the
world where we started down this
road towards corporatism which I what I
call them the uh the merger this corrupt
merger of state and corporate power that
is driven by large Industries like
pharmaceutical oil and coal Industries
the pesticide Industries
but uh the spear tip of course is what
Eisenhower warned us about uh four days
before my uncle took office
which was the rise of the military
industrial complex which has turned
America into a Warfare state
abroad and a surveillance State at home
and which has gutted the middle class in
this country we spent eight trillion
dollars on Wars since the war in Iraq
and we've got nothing in return
literally actually worse than nothing
we've undermined uh our own position in
the world we've destabilized the Mideast
we've driven 2 million refugees into
Europe
where they have destabilized democracy
all over Europe and probably account for
brexit the success of brexit
and at home you know we've hollowed out
the middle class and then you add
another 16 trillion dollars
that we spent on covid and again on the
lockdowns and got nothing in return for
that and you have a 24 trillion dollar
bill that is paid by the American middle
class in the United States is printing
money uh you know like we're borrowing 6
billion a day from the Chinese and
Japanese to pay that the interest on
those debts and it's no wonder we don't
have a middle class left in America and
when you have a
configuration now where it's
increasingly look like these large
concentrations of wealth among the you
know the growing oligarchy of
billionaires
and then widespread poverty below you
cannot have democracy for very long well
listen there's no there's no doubt just
to jump in there's no doubt that your
message is resonating with a lot of
people I mean I think if you're Joe
Biden you just announced you're running
again for president and you see that
your nearest competitor suddenly is you
at 21 in these polls and you know that a
lot of Democrats don't want you to run
again a lot of Democrats think Joe Biden
is simply too old I mean could the
unthinkable happen do you genuinely
think you could actually prevent Joe
Biden becoming the nominee
well my my objective appears is not to
prevent him from becoming a nominee my
objective is to make myself the nominee
and do I think that's possible yeah and
I'll tell you
my wife if I had not been having it
persuade the her that it was possible
would not be I would not be going along
with this Enterprise
it would be a startling thing there were
two there were two question marks about
you I mean a lot of people give you
great credit for a lifetime of work with
the environment for example with poverty
you've done a lot of great things there
are two contentious things from my
perspective uh and I'll come to the
vaccine part in a minute because that's
been a 15-year Mission by you which I
want to discuss but one thing in
particular I'm surprised about you you
are a Democrat and you come from a
family of great Democrats and yet for
some reason you've gone along with this
Donald Trump line about stolen elections
and so on why
I I don't I don't know what you're
talking about
I haven't uh I mean
well you've been seen on podiums with
people who are completely in transit and
you know if they think that what that
Donald Trump had the election stolen
that January 6 was justified and so on
why would you yeah
well if you're asking me another
question because what you're saying
about me complaining about this on an
election I complained about a stolen
election in 2001 and I wanna
I wrote an award-winning article about
the theft of the 2004 election but I
have not spoken out about this election
I don't believe it was stolen about
Trump's no no I'm talking yeah I I think
I'm talking about I'm talking about why
you're asking me yeah let me rephrase
the question I'm not actually preparing
comparing I just don't think it's
healthy for any democracy whether you're
talking about the one that you claim has
stolen the one that Trump does that
people talk about elections being stolen
in a democracy like America because it
makes people disbelieve the Democratic
process that's really the point I was
making
otherwise you're manipulating people if
you don't tell the truth I mean the
press the job of an advocate like me is
to tell the truth whether the truth is
unpleasant for people or not and you
know I I documented I mean I don't think
any Democrat
believes that the 2001 election it was
not was legit you know that's that was
Gore uh and and the New York Times
nobody else you know they ultimately
concluded yeah that yeah it was stolen
so I don't think what I said is radical
or is you know
is causing Revolution but let me ask the
other question let me ask the other
question
why do I appear why do I talk to
Republicans why do I go on Fox News and
my reason for that I do those I talk to
people who don't agree with me and I
believe that is critical for a democracy
we have a toxic polarization in this
country right now that is more dangerous
than the American Civil War if we don't
talk to people who don't agree with us
how are we going to persuade them how
are we going to find Common Ground how
are we going to end this polarization I
have always well I agree I agree with
you on my opponents on the other side I
agree with you on that and by the way I
talked to them but I do not compromise
my values I believe in all the
democratic values that I was raised with
but I believe that we should talk to
people from okay so so let's just move
quickly if we made just to this issue of
vaccines if you were to become president
you've been opposed to vaccines now for
a long time very heavily critical of the
covid vaccine that's not true well you
know you're not a vaccine denier but you
are a very very skeptical very public
voice of skepticism about the efficacy
of vaccines would that be fair
what I've said is vaccines I'm not an
anti-vaccine I think vaccines should be
subject to the same level rigorous
testing as other medications and that is
the only thing my only position listen
I fought to get Mercury out of fish for
40 years and nobody called me any fish
I'm not adding vaccines just because I
want safe vaccines and I think everybody
wants safe vaccines and as we all now
recognize the covet vaccines were
neither safe nor effective well that is
but that is a thing
hang on that is as you know heavily
disputed by a lot of top scientists who
say that comparative to other vaccines
it was very safe obviously like all
vaccines it's had issues obviously they
had to move at the speed of light
because it was a novel virus that was
killing a lot of people but it wasn't an
unsafe vaccine but all vaccines
unfortunately have side effects for a
certain percentage of people that take
them
well the that I mean that of course the
question appears are the side effects on
this vaccine vaccine number one
they avert more problems than they cause
I would argue that the science is very
clear right now that they cause a lot
more problems than they have heard it
and if you look at the countries that
did not vaccinate they had the lowest
death rates they had the lowest covet
and infection rates and if you look at
the Johns Hopkins data which is the data
everybody relies on
there's a direct correlation between
excess deaths and nations in the western
Nations
that heavily vaccinated and the level of
covet vaccination so if you look at
excess tests how many people
how many people died that shouldn't have
died at the end of the year
the vaccine caught is associated because
we don't know we can't say cause because
it's a correlation but the big the the
hot the the death in the Nations that
heavily vaccinated which were much
higher than those that didn't I I'll
give you an example we in our country
for the most have one of the most
heavily vaccinated countries in the
world
we also had the highest coveted death
rate in the world so we had we have 4.2
percent of the global population we have
16 percent of the of the covet deaths
that's not a success story how can
anybody
unfortunately we've run out of time
listen I've got to go into there but we
I definitely don't think America was a
success story and that's that's for
another time we've unfortunately run out
of time Robert I do really enjoy talking
to you I think you're a fascinating
candidate in in this whole race and the
fact you're doing so well means what
you're saying about a number of issues
is resonating and it'll be very
interesting to see how you go so thank
you very much indeed for joining me
thanks for having me peers anytime
well it says the next a person who
produces sperm is now the new
description of a boy or a man in America
we'll discuss that next
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
this is absolutely unbelievable
it's give me this phrase again
a person who produces sperm is now what
a school district in America has called
a boy or man thoughts and a person who
produces eggs is what they're calling a
person that is otherwise what is this
about as a woman what are they scared of
and this is aimed at by this is aimed at
10 year olds it's ridiculous I have a 10
year old they would just laugh at that
and be bewildered I mean why make sex
education so much more complicated but
how have we got to this Richard what
how's language got to this I've no idea
this sort of political correctness but
the most terrifying thing appears it
actually confuses children it causes
anxiety my view is it's therefore
damaging children particularly with this
gender ideologism and in that sense it's
actually a safeguarding issue no ifs no
buts in my view we just shouldn't be
going I've done my anti-woke manifest
over the sun tomorrow because somebody
wrote them saying I should be ministered
for anti-wokery so I've done my 20 and
it's quite easy to do a 20-point
Manifesto you just basically restore all
common sense I mean you asked how we've
got to this because parents are
accepting it parents yeah that I would
take my child out of a school that was
going to insist on that kind of night
and the other parents should actually
just rebel against it don't accept it
but actually many parents weren't aware
of it until it's been highlighted on
these shows and suddenly I think parents
are rebelling people I'm talking about I
think the woke worm is turning and we're
helping to turn it that's all we've got
time for I've blown it with YouTube
tonight I'm sorry we only got to talk
about sperm but it was a great time
thank you both very much
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you